Nous sommes à l'époque préhistorique,
juste avant qu'un homme préhistorique
raconte à tout le monde sa formidable découverte préhistorique.
Ça fait beaucoup de fois
"préhistorique" quand même.
Ça va.
Ouah,
elle est bien cette peau de bête.
Tu l'as trouvée où?
Sur une bête.
Eh les mecs, les mecs!
J'ai trouvé un truc
incroyablement bon à manger!
Oh, fuyez tous, fuyez!
Non, mais pourquoi?
Pourquoi?
Je vais t'expliquer pourquoi.
Regarde-moi:
T'es dangereux!
Je suis quoi? Je compr...
Ah, oiseau!
T'es dan-ge-reux, ok?
La dernière fois que t'as trouvé
un truc qui était bon,
ce qui l'ont mangé
ils se sont allongés,
après ils parlaient plus,
après ils sentaient super mauvais,
après ils sont devenus
tous maigres et tous blancs,
après on en a fait des couteaux.
Ah ouais?
Et qu'est-ce qui prouve
que c'est parce qu'ils ont mangé
du caca de mammouth?
Ecoute, si c'était comestible,
tous les animaux en mangeraient.
Ben tous les animaux en mangent
mec!
Ben non.
-Ben si.
Ouah! Il parle!
Ben oui.
C'est un perroquet-dactile.
Ouah! Tu parles!
Ben non.
Ben si tu parles
Ben non
-Si, tu...
Second degré, non,
ça te dit quelque chose?
Ouah, je viens de me faire bâcher
par un oiseau.
Je suis pas là deux semaines,
il se passe trop de trucs.
Bon écoute,
je vais être direct,
niveau nourriture je te fais plus confiance.
- Tu me fais plus quoi?
Con-fiance!
C'est le concept qu'on a tous voté
la semaine dernière.
T'es chiant.
Arrête de manger du caca
et viens en réunion,
on essaye de faire
progresser l'espèce nous.
Et qui a découvert le miel?
Toi.
Mais tu le mangeais
avec les abeilles dedans.
Ah ouais...
Mais les recettes
on les trouvera plus tard.
Non parce qu'on te croit plus,
c'est fini on veut plus te suivre.
On a peur de toi.
Non mais là ce que j'ai trouvé
c'est la meilleure boisson!
Non.
Allez!
-Non.
Bon, faut grimper un arbre?
Non.
l faut creuser dans un truc
où il y a plein d'autres trucs
qui truquent?
Heu,
il faut trouver des noms aux trucs.
Et ben viens en réunion!
Et arrête de ...
Manger du caca,
je sais.
Bon, il faut s'approcher d'un animal sauvage?
Non mec,
je te dis, c'est facile.
C'est facile?
-Ouais.
Ok, dis.
Il faut sucer une vache.
Et tu bois le blanc.
Je me casse.
Et c'est ainsi
que depuis ce jour,
les animaux ne nous ont plus jamais
adressé la parole.
En tout cas d'après des chaussettes.